hey what's up my name's samuel leeds i'm
a property investor and in this video i
want to answer
all of my subscribers
property investment questions so if
you're a subscriber to this channel and
you like my videos please do me a favor
hit the like button but more importantly
in the comment box comment your property
investment questions and i'll do my best
to answer your questions for next week's
q a sunday video if it's niggling maybe
it's been holding you back you're
struggling on a deal you need a little
bit of support or maybe you are stuck on
what something means you've been hearing
a piece of jargon or or you need some
help with
structuring a deal or understanding
lease options rent any
that you have no matter how basic or
complex
comment it below and i will do my best
to answer it for next week if you are
not a subscriber of the channel then
please subscribe and then hit your
comments below in the comment box and
i'll answer your question too and i look
forward to seeing what questions you've
got in the meantime what did we have
last week so we had a guy called vito
who i believe is a subscriber and vito
said i'm in the middle of purchasing my
first property thanks to your videos
hope to be on winners on a wednesday in
a couple of months
why don't
anyway i tried to land a lease option
agreement but instead agreed on a
different type of rent to buy deal it's
a no money down deal i'll be paying off
the property in a course of seven years
as someone who's never bought a house
before
would you recommend i open a limited
company to do this or in my own
name
great question vito so firstly you've
done the hard bit
my friend the fact that you've secured a
no money down deal where you're going to
be buying now paying over the course of
the next seven years
absolutely brilliant congratulations i
have no doubt to see you on windows on a
wednesday uh in terms of should you buy
in a company or in your personal name
it's more it's more of a tax uh it
depends
it depends on i don't know your
situation i don't know if you're a high
rate taxpayer if you're a high rate
taxpayer then definitely limited company
there are tax savings to this also if
it's a if it's like a delayed sale
it might make sense to have a company
set up
but i would probably say you've done the
hard bit pick up the phone have a
conversation with a property accountant
tell them about the deal and they'll be
able to advise you best and take into
account all of your situation but
massive respect buddy and uh well done
let me know how that goes
smith jones
i recently purchased my first buy to let
through auction congratulations another
subscriber if you're not subscribed by
the way subscribe and hit your question
below
i paid 45 000 pounds cash with a sitting
tenant
the rent is paid directly from the local
housing authority every four weeks
however
when i purchased there was no tenancy
agreement
should i be worried
also what's the best way for me to buy
my next property i.e refinance or saving
rental income and my wages from work to
buy my next property i've learned so
much from you thanks for reply in
advance so smith weldon for taking
action super excited to see how that
goes should you be worried um
i wouldn't be worried but it is a
problem
buying a house from auction and the
tenants aren't
you haven't got their contract maybe the
previous landlord lost the tenancy
agreement or something like that it is a
little bit of a concern because if you
haven't got a tenancy agreement when you
complete on the house effectively those
tenants are almost like squatters
also the council who are they paying are
they paying the previous landlord so
you're going to need to get that
switched over so they stopped paying you
really important um i have had this
situation before and i've never had an
issue what i've done is i've approached
the tenants and i've gone hey
i'm gonna be completing on the property
next week good to meet you really nice
to them check the properties like is
there anything at least fixing are you
okay
be really sweet to them and then say oh
obviously you know we're gonna need to
switch the agreements over so that
you're dealing with me direct i'm going
to be looking after you really really
looking forward to it um
would it be all right if i come around
with the new contract next week and then
we can get that signed out ready and
then i'll be your point of contact and
normally if they know the house is being
sold or you're the new they normally
will just go yeah man sure but if they
don't see if they go no i'm not signing
it no
you might have some problems so fingers
crossed
kasim shakir
firstly you want to say thank you for
answering my previous question you're
welcome man um
just a follow-up question can i do
whatever i want
with the money received from
refinancing what i mean is i'm currently
a higher rate taxpayer so i want to set
up a new limited company
loan the money i get from the lender to
that company and make future purchases
via the company am i allowed to do that
kazeem yes i see no problems with you
doing that
listen some of these questions about
literature companies and tax and things
like that just to say um you know my um
my my guidance on this video is of
course general guidance from my
experience so i can't give you like tax
advice or anything like that i can only
speak from my experience so do always
get solicitors and accountants to look
at your situation when you're purchasing
properties and loaning money however
kasim there's no reason why you
shouldn't be able to do that at all i've
done that many many times if you
refinance the property you pull out the
equity um you can do it you walk with
that money
you go on holiday with the money you'd
be stupid to do that you can buy you can
loan it to a company and then buy
so uh
yeah and it's tax-free because when you
when you refinance that money is debt
so you know you're going to get taxed on
debt so good good good stuff and let me
know how it goes
all right salahuddin imran
can you flip houses on a residential
mortgage
or
do you have to pay early termination
penalty penalty please can someone
advise
salahuddin imran um yeah if you buy a
property on a residential mortgage
normally that mortgage will be fixed so
you won't be able to pay it back pay the
mortgage off for a minimum of one to two
years that's about standard
so
if you're buying a property and the
intention is to flip it
i would just say probably just wait a
year or two before you sell it otherwise
you are gonna get charged early payment
fees because if a mortgage company is
lending you say a hundred grand to buy a
house
and they're saying pay me three percent
back per year
and in their minds they're going to be
making three grand a year
but then after six months if you just go
here's your money back and here's your
grand and a half interest
it's not worth the paperwork for them
it's not worth taking you on as a
customer messing around for a grand and
a half so they're going to want you to
commit to borrowing that money for at
least
x amount of months
so
if you do pull out early they might
charge it you're not going to pay a load
of money you might pay a couple of grand
so
it's not if you're if you're doing flips
on a residential mortgage that's fine in
fact it's probably the best way to do it
because on a residential mortgage you're
going to put down a very small deposit
so you're not tying got much money also
if you're living in the property you're
not going to pay any capital gains tax
when you sell the property which also is
a massive bonus if you do get hit with a
small early repayment charge it's not a
massive deal depending on the profit in
the deal but it might just be worth
waiting a little bit longer to sell it
um and then avoiding that fee
hope that helps if you enjoy the video
folks hit the like button if you have
questions subscribe to the channel and
go ahead and comment your questions in
the chat box
james cassidy
do you generally have to leave 25 of the
value of the house in the property when
we're mortgaging
the answer is yes
if it's a buy to let that's very
standard however
25 of the value of the house you can
increase the value of the house
so if you buy if you're refinancing a
house that's worth a hundred grand
you're gonna
be able to borrow
75 percent namely 75 000 pounds of the
value which is 100 grand
but if you buy the house for 100 but
then you increase the value by doing
something like maybe title splitting the
property
or
fixing an issue or if the property is
unmortgageable because there's no
kitchen or there's no hot water if you
buy a property 100 grand and then fix it
fix the problem and then push the value
up to 150
you're then going to be able to borrow
75
of the new higher value
so that that's the strategy that's what
we that's what we do hope that helps all
right last question charles royal
if i have 10 grand spare how should i
spend it
well first thing is you shouldn't spend
it
if you've got 10 grand don't spend it
you should invest
it
it's a big difference between investing
money and spending money
so how should you invest it
well i would probably say if you've got
10 grand
rather than putting that 10 grand
down as a down payment to buy a house
let's face it 10 grand isn't enough to
buy a house if you've got 10 grand
even if you buy a really cheap house you
can't find house i mean what's the
cheapest house in the country 30 35
grand but you won't get a mortgage on a
house that cheap
so if it's 40 50 grand
one's going to need more than 10 grand
especially with your stamp duty and your
legals so 10 grand won't even get you
the cheapest hat you just can't buy a
house for 10 grand
even if you could even if you had 20
grand i'd be like well it might be just
enough to buy a house which is then
going to make you 200 a month profit
be it's not hardly life-changing
my advice if you've got 10 grand rather
than investing into a property i would
invest it into
your property
business
i would put it into setting up a rent to
rent business
a deal sourcing business
i'd put some of it into your education
i'd put some of it into getting your
website drawn up down payments on a
rented rent
i would be putting that 10 grand to get
yourself an up and running cash flowing
cash producing business
and then your business is going to start
making you cash flow
more than 10 grand
and that 10 grand
oh sorry that cash flow i would then
start investing that into something
that's going to give you passive income
as a property investor you can either
invest money
or you can be a property entrepreneur
and you can make money with property and
i think you should do both so i'd put
that 10 grand into a property cash
producing
business and then with that money invest
it and slowly build up passive income
over time as well as active income
hope that makes sense if you need any
more help
comment below in the chat box or if you
want to join me at one of my
up-and-coming property investment
training courses guess what most of my
training courses are free and if you
want to come and meet me spend a day
together come down to some training
courses
then below i'll leave a link in the
description on the house come and meet
me let's train you up let's see you
getting some results and thank you so
much for watching this video subscribe
hit like and i'll see you on the
training program real soon peace